[Musica]
conoscete i videogiochi
molti di voi probabilmente li utilizzano
come svago
altri invece per incontrare i propri
amici durante le varie serate
molti di voi probabilmente hanno
cominciato a utilizzare i videogiochi
già in tenera età altri invece è magari
da un po più adulti
ci sono addirittura molte persone che
non ho preso la distanza io vi racconto
invece la mia esperienza con i
videogiochi
ho iniziato a giocare quando ancora
avevo sei anni con il primo game boy e
giocava pokémon supermario ad hoc in
kong ma è stato solamente con il mio
periodo universitario che ho capito
quanto veramente i videogiochi sono
importanti per me e vi racconto questa
storiella durante i miei anni
universitari un gruppo i miei amici mi
propone di giocare ad un gioco nuovo
forse voi avete già sentito parlare di
questo gioco perché è molto famoso anche
anche adesso
e questo gioco si chiama minecraft anno
minecraft è un gioco della tipologia
sandbox cosa significa significa che è
un gioco tanti altri giochi che ha un
mondo regolato da delle regole
specifiche e un po come il nostro mondo
abbiamo la gravità abbiamo il ciclo
giorno notte abbiamo la natura avevo
tante cose e all'interno di minecraft si
può fare un po di tutto
ed è proprio questo il bello dei
videogiochi della tipologia sandbox che
non c'è una storia netta da seguire ma
ogni giocatore può crearsi dalla storia
può interagire col mondo interagire con
i personaggi può
le gare e anche con gli altri giocatori
ed è questo che è successo a me dopo
aver provato questo gioco inizialmente
in questo gruppo di amici ho iniziato a
giocati sempre di più io ho cominciato a
stringere delle relazioni delle
relazioni molto importanti come voi
sapete nei giochi online c'è sempre il
l'amico che conosci che ti porta a
giocare a questo gioco ma più tempo
passi in questo gioco più ti rendi conto
che comincia a conoscere persone persone
online in questo mondo virtuale
queste persone non magari non le conosce
nella vita di tutti i giorni ma le senti
ogni giorno le attraverso le chat vocali
ci parli girate tante cose a me ad un
certo punto però è successo qualcosa
purtroppo un giorno uno dei nostri amici
di gioco perde la vita non nel mondo del
gioco nel mondo reale e questo per me
non solo per me è stato un momento
cruciale sia della mia vita sia dalla
mia esperienza con i videogiochi
pensate una persona che non hai mai
incontrato nella vita reale ma con cui
ci hai avuto a che fare tantissimo con
cui hai condiviso emozioni arrabbiature
speranze sogni con cui hai condiviso
molte ore di gioco libero senza una
storia e a causa di questa perdita
ho cominciato a ragionare su come i
videogiochi possono influenzare e la
nostra quotidianità il nostro mondo e ho
cominciato a riflettere sempre di più
per arrivare poi ad una conclusione
i videogiochi e come tanti altri giochi
hanno un impatto concreto non solo di
divertimento di passatempo o di
conoscenza di varie persone mano proprio
un impatto diretto e allora mi sono
chiesto come si può
a sfruttare questo strumento del gioco
per andare oltre quella che è la
semplice semplice divertimento
non so se lo sapete ma ogni anno viene
scritto un report dove soprattutto qui
in italia ma viene fatto in tutto il
mondo dove vengono esposti i dati sui
videogiocatori in generale in tutto
quanto il mondo e non solo sapete ma qui
in italia nel 2020 sono stati 17 milioni
i videogiocatori e le persone che hanno
utilizzato un videogioco è dato
interessante di questi 17 milioni i
giocatori dieci milioni sono ragazzi
ragazzi che vanno dai 6 anni piccolini
fino ai 30 anni
un po più grandicelli quindi
immaginatevi 10 milioni di persone che
ogni giorno ogni settimana mediamente
dalle 6 7 ore al giorno utilizzano i
videogiochi per svagarsi e per fare
altro
ma poi un'altra riflessione è venuto in
mente negli ultimi anni
effettivamente abbiamo notato sempre di
più dei movimenti dei dibattiti
riguardanti nei temi molto caldi
il surriscaldamento globale e tutta la
parte riguardante alle disabilità al
disuguaglianza di genere la
disuguaglianza culturale e se notate
moltissimi di questi movimenti
moltissimi di questi dibattiti partono
proprio da questo target di età
si parte già dalle scuole primarie a
parlare di questi temi per arrivare poi
alle scuole secondarie e per arrivare
poi a creare dei movimenti faide four
feature per esempio e ce ne sono
tantissimi altri movimenti supportati
proprio dai giovani che chiedono di
essere ascoltati
io ho pensato di collegare queste due
tematiche ho pensato di collegare quelle
che il videogioco come strumento per poi
andarlo a utilizzare per parlare di
questi temi per far sì che anche i
giovani i giovanissimi anche quelli meno
giovani possano trovare uno strumento
nel videogioco per parlare e affrontare
questi temi
insomma per dare voce come noi sappiamo
oggi parlare di democrazia a parlare di
libertà non è mai semplice e normalmente
questo argomento si tende sempre ad
affrontarlo quando siamo un po più
adulti ma è giusto è giusto riservare
questo argomento solamente ad una fascia
di età per esempio maggiorenni
secondo me utilizzando il gioco
utilizzando i videogiochi si possono
veicolare delle informazioni molto
importanti per quanto riguarda per
esempio la libertà l'espressione la
decisione cercare di insegnare a ragazzi
e ragazze di quest'epoca che è
importante dire la propria è importante
ascoltare ed è importante il concetto di
libertà
ci sono per esempio alcuni esempi che
possiamo dire di realtà attuali che
effettivamente ci possono dare una mano
a capire come i videogiochi possono
essere collegati con questo concetto di
democrazia e avrebbe da aggiungere
democrazia digitale visto che stiamo
parlando di videogiochi per esempio
nelle ultime elezioni degli stati uniti
d'america hanno utilizzato un videogioco
per insegnare a giovani e meno giovani
come votare ma non solo come votare
anche tutto il processo del voto quindi
della camera del senato e dei grandi
elettori tutto perché molto
probabilmente i vecchi sistemi non
funzionano più
per comunicare con questo target di età
e quindi utilizzando il videogioco
si cerca sempre di superare quelle che
sono le barriere possono essere barriere
linguistiche possono essere barriere di
disabilità dovuta delle disabilità
possono anche essere barriere di classe
purtroppo ma non è solo questo l'esempio
un altro progetto che negli ultimi anni
sta prendendo piede sempre di più e il
block by blog cioè un progetto che si
impegna a fare appunto sviluppare tutto
il senso civico delle persone
all'interno di città un po diciamo
sfortunate l'esempio in kenya questo
progetto ha messo in comunicazione
quelle che sono le persone i cittadini
quello che le persone che vivono la
città contadini i lavoratori con la
classe politica quella classe dirigente
su tematiche di riqualificazione
chiedere ai cittadini quali sono i
problemi della propria città e far sì
che tutti questi argomenti vengono poi
riportati alla classe dirigente ma come
fanno come si fa a far comunicare una
persona magari analfabeta che vive la
città che se la sente propria con una
classe dirigente invece magari più
istruita i canali di comunicazione
cominciano essere difficili e utilizzare
i giochi e videogiochi
in questo caso in questo esempio hanno
utilizzato utilizzano minecraft come
come esempio si riesce a creare una
sorta di ponte tra due realtà che molte
volte comunicano può essere il contadino
e la classe dirigente possono essere i
giovani e gli adulti quindi una
generazione a confronto
inoltre vi racconto quello che è anche
la mia esperienza personale
anch'io sto portando questa scelta di
utilizzare i videogiochi come veicolo di
alcune è per me né con i valori molto
importanti
uno dei progetti che sto portando avanti
e sto portando avanti con una scuola
secondaria di primo grado del mio paese
e quello di riqualificazione del proprio
quartiere
grazie alle classi di questa scuola
secondaria di primo grado e la sua
insegnante giulia riusciamo a prendere i
ragazzi farli analizzare i quartieri
dove abitano e utilizzando i videogiochi
farli riprodurre in scala il proprio
quartiere ma non solo non è
semplicemente un copia incolla tra le
realtà il virtuale
qui si riescono ad affrontare anche
tematiche molto importanti quali per
esempio la riqualificazione urbana
l'ecosostenibilità l'eliminazione di
barriere architettoniche e assegnando a
tutte le classi un quartiere loro lo
riproducono e poi si entra in tutto quel
processo decisionale e che fa parte
della democrazia digitale quindi il
ascoltare le idee e le opinioni degli
altri dire la propria vivere in un mondo
virtuale con delle regole ma anche con
la libertà di poter fare quello che si
vuole
andrei limiti delle regole logicamente e
soprattutto di poter accettare tutto
quello che viene fatto e tutte le
opinioni degli altri senza
discriminazioni questo si può fare
all'interno dei videogiochi ed è una
parte secondo me molto importante che se
oggi ci sono ancora dei problemi legati
alla tecnologia sicuramente ci sono
ancora tante cose che si possono
migliorare ma come la tutta la
tecnologia sapevo benissimo che estate
nera sempre ad evolversi e si evolverà
anche in base alle nostre esigenze
e questa parlare di argomenti attuali
dare voce a quelle persone che in questo
momento forse non si sentono ascoltate
per me è molto importante e utilizzando
i videogiochi si può fare quindi acqua
utilizzando il videogioco noi riusciamo
anche a parlare di democrazia
parlare di scelte e cerchiamo di far
crescere e far nascere quelli che sono
che saranno i cittadini
che vivranno il nostro paese del futuro
prestando però attenzione a quelli che
sono dei valori valori fondamentali e
soprattutto facendo capire l'importanza
della parola libertà grazie
[Musica]